i've been obviously wearing the you're
wearing the the shirt obviously kobe uh
how much has he been on your mind in
this because you're doing things that
he would definitely be proud of to see
you do and then second
just this four or no start what does it
mean for the team
overall to be able to start this way in
the bubble
yeah cob's with me every day i mean
after you guys see what i put on my
shoes to be legendary that's a
you know that's a reminder that's a
reminder for me and
you know even without that reminder it
comes you know through 24 hours
at least two three times a day you know
it crosses my mind if not more
um but you know credit a good start to
you know just like i said our collective
team
you know we approached the bubble with
the right mindset we came in
um before we even got to orlando people
in phoenix working out hard just getting
ready for this opportunity
right when we figured out that we were
coming down here we took it on as a
challenge and
you know got better as a team and got
better in our training camp down here
the first two weeks